mich hat heute eine Meldung der
Sportschau beschäftigt die für Furore
gesorgt hat die Nachricht bezahlte
Fanreisen zur Katar WM das klingt ja
erstmal wie in einem Märchen eine gute
Fee erscheint und verteilt mit ihrem
glitzernden Zauberstab ein
leidenschaftlicher Fans Flüge
Unterbringung und sogar taschengelder
zur WM klingt doch großartig doch in
diesem Fall ist die gute Fee eher der
böse Wolf denn die kostenlosen Fanreisen
beinhalten ein Verhaltenskodex und 450
Fans aus 59 Ländern seinen beteiligt die
Teilnehmer des fanlieder-netzwerks
müssen unter dem Slogan Katar the fans
World Cup und dem Hashtag i am Fan
fröhlich posten die Teilnehmenden Fans
die wissen auch also deren Reise bezahlt
wird dass ihre Social Media Beiträge
beobachtet werden man behält sich auch
das Recht vor Änderungen oder das
Löschen von Post zu verlangen